today on the matt wall show a report
from the surgeon general shows the
extent of the damage coveted lockdowns
did to children although that's not the
lesson the government wants us to take
from the report we'll talk about that
and blm comes out in support of jesse
smallette big surprise media matters
launches an attack on the most prominent
and revered lgbt author in the nation if
you can believe it and prince harry says
that if your job doesn't bring you joy
you should just quit is that good career
advice from a guy who's never had a
career we'll talk about that and much
more today on the matt well show
[Applause]
[Music]
well you guys know that i am a my pillow
addict uh i cannot sleep really with
with any pillow or blanket or anything
that is not a my pillow product because
they all
are once once you try the my pillow you
never want to try anything else and
that's why it's so great that my pillow
uh just in time for the holidays wants
to give back to our listeners you can
get great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com right
now and click on the radio listener
specials get deep discounts on my
pillows mattress toppers towels and so
much more
for example my pillow is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza sheets
these are the top quality sheets that
you will absolutely love again try these
sheets you're not going to want to use
any other sheets again
and we got them buy one get one free all
my pillow products come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty go to mypillar.com and click on
the radio listener specials for the buy
one get one free offer on the giza
sheets and use promo code daily wire
check out or call 800-651-1148
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including pillow uh the
the pillow obviously slippers the my
pillow mattress topper and the my pillow
towel sets all of that that's
mypillow.com and enter dailywire or call
1-800-651-1148 tell them dailywire sent
you that's 1-800-651-1148
the surgeon general of the united states
issued a report this week which
contained some extremely troubling
though not at all unexpected information
it's 53 pages long and details the
mental health challenges quote unquote
that children have experienced over the
last year and mental health challenges
is an understatement the surgeon general
dr murthy says that most of these uh
problems can be blamed on the
coronavirus pandemic now as usual with
our government even when they correctly
identify a problem which is rare they
still make the wrong diagnosis that's
what they've done here here's the new
york times with more on the report it
says
the report cited significant increases
in self-reports of depression anxiety
and emergency room visits for mental
health challenges in the united states
emergency room visits for suicide
attempts rose 51
for adolescent girls in early 2021 as
compared with the same period in 2019
the figure rose four percent for boys
globally symptoms of anxiety depression
doubled during the pandemic the report
noted but mental health issues were
already on the rise in the united states
with emergency room visits related to
depression anxiety and related issues up
28 between 2011 and 2015.
now a 51 rise in suicide attempts among
adolescent girls in one year is
staggering catastrophic
four percent rise in one year among boys
is already enormous
but 51 is uh unthinkable
it's an epidemic in every sense of the
word
it's also exactly what many of us warned
would happen
that's what make this that's what makes
this all the more tragic and infuriating
it was predictable and thus it was
preventable
but the powers that be are determined to
miss the point
because they don't care about the point
they don't care about kids they don't
care about anybody
back to the article it says the reasons
are complex and not yet definitive
adolescent brain chemistry and
relationships with friends and family
are important factors the report noted
as is a fast-paced media culture which
can leave some young minds feeling
helpless
young people are bombarded with messages
through the media and popular culture
that erode their sense of self-worth
telling them they're not good-looking
enough popular enough smart enough or
rich enough dr murthy wrote in the
report that comes as progress on
legitimate and distressing issues like
climate change income inequality racial
injustice the opioid epidemic epidemic
and gun violence feels too slow
okay no children are not attempting
suicide because of climate change or
racial
injustice although the fear-mongering
done on these issues certainly doesn't
help matters i'm sure it can contribute
to an overall feeling of despair and
hopelessness when the adults in your
life are all telling you that the world
is doomed and your neighborhood will be
underwater in 10 years and the planet is
dead and on top of it all there are
legions of white supremacists and racist
murderous cops prowling the streets
executing racial minorities at will
and on top of that if you're white that
you're born with a with the stain of
guilt with blood on your hands that you
can't wash off and if you're black
you're born a victim and you'll never
not be a victim i mean all that stuff
doesn't help
i have no doubt that this messaging
contributes significantly to the problem
but that's not climate change or racial
inequality hurting a child's mental
health it's the things that adults are
saying about those subjects
the false claims they're making which
are causing the damage
and the damage is intentional again
likewise the coronavirus has almost
nothing to do with any of this
not almost it has nothing to do with any
of this
there has not been a 51 increase in
suicide attempts due to the coronavirus
if the virus was dangerous to kids and
children across the country had to see
their friends die from it
and worry that they might be next then
we could draw probably a straight line
connection between covid to the child
suicide epidemic but that's not the case
this is a mild disease for kids in most
cases what's hurting them isn't covet
itself but our response to it also keep
in mind that there have been uh
pandemics
throughout the course of human
civilization
many of them much worse than this and
many of them affecting kids much more
than this one has
polio for example
during those occasions did we see mass
epidemics of child suicide
i don't think we did
so why is it happening now
well because kids were isolated for no
good reason torn out of their normal
routines and social lives for no good
reason made to wear masks
for years on end now
deprived of the ability to see their
friends faces and to be seen
to see people and be seen
is one of the most elemental fundamental
aspects of living in a human society and
we took that away
they were treated as though they were
diseased and encouraged to treat
everybody else the same
we we made them afraid of social contact
with other people
afraid of the very air they breathe
this is still going on in many places in
the country look at this video from a
post-millennial reporter in portland
she says uh here's the caption with the
video she says kindergartners are forced
to eat lunch outside in 40 degree
weather at capitol hill elementary
school in portland oregon they sit on
buckets to social distance from their
classmates you can see the video there
they're sitting on the ground
in 40 degree temperatures
and um and they've got buckets for i
don't know if that's buckets for
tables or buckets for chairs
now we don't treat prison inmates like
this
if this was footage from a prison
with inmates forced to sit on the ground
in the cold with buckets as tables
isolated we would call it cruel and
unusual punishment
a lot of people would i probably
wouldn't if it was prisoners
people would say things like you know
even a convicted murderer doesn't
deserve to be treated that way and yet a
child does
then they go back into class with their
masks on faceless entities around other
faceless entities
sitting behind desks with plastic
barriers between them and their
classmates
most of their of their parents still
won't let them socialize like normal
after school with their friends they go
home and sit behind a computer screen
it's the only place where they can be
normal and free except the internet is
poison for their minds just like it's
poisoned for hours as adults
now the surgeon general
connects the internet to this and i
think for good reason
i mean it is not a coincidence at all
that we've got
the child suicide epidemic which as the
report points out was already a rising
problem uh before
the
lockdowns and and and this is all like
unheard of in in through through human
civilization up until now
to have all these kids at such young
ages contemplating suicide or committing
suicide
this has never happened before
it's not a coincidence that it's
happening now while the internet takes
over everybody's lives
and it's it's afflicting a generation
that has that has been raised in
cyberspace they've never known a life
outside of it
but what's the connection i mean the
surgeon general worries that kids on the
internet are learning that they're not
good looking enough they're not popular
enough they're not smart enough or rich
enough
this is superficial surface level
analysis of the dangers of the internet
it's not wrong per se
but the problem runs much deeper than
that
after all as long as there's been pop
culture and media there have always been
people
staring at screens and feeling uglier
and less popular in comparison to what
they see inside the magic box
but and even before that there have
always been people
looking at other people and saying well
that person's more attractive that
person's you know has a better
personality they're more popular or
whatever that kind of thing has always
happened
but with the internet a child's and this
is really true of all of us but we're
talking about kids right now a child's
mind is altered his whole way of being
it's not just a tv where you're watching
things happen where you're a mere viewer
the internet is and now even more so
because of the way kids have been
isolated it's the primary mode of
engagement with the world you don't just
watch you engage
you present yourself to the world
you see on the tv the world presents
itself to you and that's problematic
enough because the presentation that
you're seeing is not is is is
not accurate
and you can get some wrong ideas about
the world
but through the internet you're getting
a false presentation of the world while
you present yourself a false
presentation of yourself to the world
your presentation of yourself is not
real it's an avatar and now with the
metaverse on the way we'll be we will
become avatars in a more literal sense
but that will only be an escalation of a
process that's already been underway
the more that kids live their lives on
the internet the more that they're
deprived
of an authentic self it's not just that
they feel badly about themselves it's
that they they don't have a self at all
they don't have a firm identity
when you see all these kids running
around with all their lgbt labels and
they've got 50 different labels and it
changes by the day and their pronouns
change by the day i mean these are these
are kids who have no identity they have
no sense of self at all they don't know
anything about themselves
they've been subsumed into cyberspace
and nothing is real there there's
nothing firm or consistent to anchor
yourself to
now i said that this is how they engage
with the world but that's not exactly
true
because engage makes it sound too
purposeful and active most of us kids
especially engage with the internet in a
state that's something like highway
hypnosis
you scroll and click and type
barely noticing what you're doing
or the hours ticking off the clock
or the days and months and years and
lives that you've wasted
now none of this began with kovud or
more precisely with our response to
covet but that's made it a lot worse
literally every significant problem
our kids already faced by nature of
living in the modern world was made
worse
much worse by the coveted policies
they've been living under and suffering
under for two years
and now the people responsible for this
will act surprised
but they should have known
and they didn't know
they knew exactly what they were doing
this was simply a trade they were
willing to make
for their own sakes
your kid's life for theirs
that's the trade
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i know my family we have we do have a
front door but we are one of those
families like it seems like every family
we do this weird thing where you never
use the front door and so we always use
the the garage the door that goes
through the garage and that's so many
families that's so many households
that's exactly what they do in fact
garages are the most frequently accessed
entry to the home but they're often
overlooked the garage is where you know
the people most important to you come
and go and it houses many of your most
prized possessions including your cars
tools and bikes so it's just common
sense to know what's going on in there
even though so often when we think about
security we neglect that part of the
house
which is pretty ridiculous when you
think about it introducing the myq smart
camera by chamberlain the only smart
camera optimized for the garage brought
to you by the leaders in garage door
opener technology with features like
live video streaming recorded events
motion detection and two-way
communication right from your phone you
can make sure your garage is secured 24
7. pair it with the myq smart garage
control and you'll never have to worry
if you left the garage door open so if
you're like me and you're driving to
work and then you start thinking did i
close the garage did i do this or that
you could just go on your phone and take
care of it there so what are you waiting
for give the gift of the my q smart
garage camera to tech lovers this season
if you act now you could save 46 for a
limited time by entering walsh at
checkout or on myq dot com slash walsh
that was wall should check out on my
queue.com walsh to save 46
yeah by the way i was just talking about
uh how you know when you the kids wear
the masks and they're deprived of the
ability to to see and be seen and um i
thought of an essay that i
read very recently by the writer
jonathan franzen and um
he was from what i remember in the essay
he was he was talking about the
experience he wrote that essay in like
90s 1998 or something 1997. it was in
the 90s and it was it was when uh maybe
the early 2000s when
people were first starting to use cell
phones it was like the big bulky cell
phones and people they weren't on the
internet they were just texting
um
or you know just staring down at them
and he's talking about the experience
lamenting it like walking down a
sidewalk in new york and uh and now it's
this new thing where everybody passes by
they're just looking down at their
phones
and he says something like the one thing
i want from a sidewalk is to
see people and be seen
and
and
that's what we've lost because of the
internet
um no matter where you are in public you
know you're sitting in a like a waiting
room somewhere waiting to get your oil
changed it used to be that you would sit
there
and
there'd be other people around and uh
god forbid you'd make some small talk or
something at least you just like you'd
be aware of the presence of other people
and you'd be you'd have this shared
experience with them might not be the
most profound experience but it's some
kind of shared experience waiting there
and now it's no one even looks you don't
even know who's
you you leave and you you got your oil
change and anybody asked you to describe
anybody who was in the room with you you
couldn't do it because you didn't even
notice them um so that was already a
problem but i talked about how
our reaction to covet has exacerbated
all these problems that already existed
and now with and now with masks and are
putting our kids in masks all the time
and when you when you live like where i
do it's it's hard to even fathom that
this is still happening because i go out
and i don't see any masks
but traveling around the country in many
places in the country it's still
everywhere and so there are still
millions of kids
who
all they need from a sidewalk
or walking down the hallway at school is
to see and be seen and they don't have
that they can't see anything all they
see is eyes they see no faces
the psychological damage of that alone i
mean isolate that little piece alone
okay let's let's raise millions of kids
in an environment where we deprive them
of the ability to see to have their
faces seen and see other people's faces
and let's do that for years and see what
happens this is like a social experiment
that alone
the psychological damage being done is
hard to fathom but then you put it on
top of everything else and
what do you get well you get 51 suicide
attempts
all right uh we'll start with this
blm.com has uh just put out a statement
and a statement regarding the ongoing
trial of jesse smallette
now keep in mind of course nobody was
really asking blm
their opinion on this nobody was that no
one asks blm's opinion on anything
nobody wants to know or care
but um they've gone out of their way
so it's not like they were backed into a
corner and they had to say something
about jesse's mullet they could have
said nothing at all and nobody would
have noticed
but they wrote this statement put it
right up on the website
big headline
and here's what they have to say about
it
they say as abolitionists we approach
situations of injustice with love and
align ourselves
we approach situations of injustice with
love
and with a torch
so that we can set the buildings on fire
um and we align ourselves with our
community and they align themselves with
their community by burning it to the
ground that's one way of doing it
because we got us
wait what
we align ourselves with our community
because we got us
i don't even know what that means
this is a statement from dr molina
abdullah
so this is a doctor for some fake doctor
probably but a highly educated person
and this is what they're writing because
we got us
so let's be clear
we love everybody in our community
it's not about a trial or a verdict
decided in a white supremacist charade
it's about how we treat our community
when corrupt systems are working to
devalue their lives
in an abolitionist society this trial
would not be taking place and our
communities would not have to fight and
suffer to prove our worth
instead we find ourselves once again
being forced to put our lives and our
value in the hands of judges and juries
operating in a system that is designed
to oppress us while continuing to face a
corrupt and violent police department
who has proven time and again to have no
respect for our lives
in our commitment to abolition we can
never believe police especially the
chicago police department over jesse
smallette a black man who has been
courageously present visible and vocal
in the struggle for black freedom while
policing at large is an irredeemable
institution cpd is notorious for its
long and deep history of corruption
racism and brutality
um blah blah blah and so on and so forth
so
they're supporting justice mullet is
what they're trying to say but
and they and they say well if we we
believe jesse smelled instead of the
chicago police department
but what they don't do here and i'm not
going to read the entire statement i've
already read more than you probably
needed to hear
but what they don't do is lay out the
reasons why they they believe jesse
smellet
which if they had good reasons you'd
think they'd do that
they would they would have their
bulletproof points and their their case
that they would make and they would say
look here's why boom boom boom he's
clearly innocent
they don't do that they have one line we
believe jesse smile instead of the
chicago police department
and uh and then the rest of it is all
about systemic racism and everything
else
what they're ignoring of course they're
ignoring a lot which just basic common
sense and the fact that the evidence is
utterly overwhelming but also
um if this is a he said he said
situation it's not justice mollet
versus the chicago police department
it's jesse smallett versus the
nigerian
brothers
one of whom is was his gay lover at one
point according to
him are they part of this white
supremacist system they're the ones who
said the only reason really that justice
malevolent is on trial right now
is that the brothers came out and
admitted what happened
and yes threw justice light under the
bus at the same time because it was
either it was either going to be
him or them
so i guess they're part of the white
supremacist system
that's what this trial is without the
brothers admitting it then we'd still
know that it was fake but they probably
wouldn't have them on trial because they
wouldn't have
they'd still have a significant amount
of evidence
but it would all be sort of like
negative evidence it would it would be
evidence like well you claim that these
people are out there we didn't see
anything in the security cameras
but here there's positive evidence we
have positive evidence that this was
faked because we got the two guys that
you uh conspired with saying that it was
fake and oh yeah here's the check you
wrote them
for the fake hate crime
and um
even though justice millett described
his attackers as white and then pale
you know i can tell you that nigerians
are neither of those things so
um really these are two black men from
africa
it's their word if you want to look at
it this way against jesse smellette
and so if you're if you're trying if
that's if we're doing this based on
identity
who's more trustworthy based on their
identity and where they fall on the
victim scale
wouldn't be black immigrants from africa
wouldn't wouldn't they be the ones that
you would rally behind
justice millett's whole their whole case
is uh is
yeah they're
they're trying to pay the chicago police
department as racist but really their
whole case is to throw the brothers
under the bus
they have their closing arguments there
so the defense is turning a closing
argument the whole closing argument is
that these guys are you know psychopaths
and they and they this is all them this
is all their fart fault uh go after them
yes i did say this is all their fault
forget about that
that's their whole case
so it's two black men from africa
against the word of a black guy a rich
wealthy privileged black guy in america
but black lives matter they don't the
point is they don't care about the truth
obviously they don't care about what
actually happened they don't care about
black people they don't care about any
of the things they talk about
this is all politics this is all power
that's all it is
all right let's move on to this
very distressing news here um
this is from media matters
it says
headline amazon's best-selling lgbtq
book is a hateful picture book comparing
being trans to pretending to be a walrus
the best-selling lgbtq plus book on
amazon is johnny the walrus a hateful
picture book by the daily wires matt
walsh that compares the gender
identities of trans youth to a young boy
who imagines he's a walrus
amazon mislabeled the book into its
lgbtq book section and as a result it's
promoting harmful anti-trans views to
its consumers interested in lgbtq
stories
and then they go on
this is this is outrageous and very
upsetting for me
and i was worried that this would happen
that this kind of homophobia and gay
erasure would happen
but for media matters to be doing it is
beyond the pale
for them to be going after and attacking
the most prominent the most revered the
most respected and beloved and
best-selling lgbt author not just in the
nation but in the world okay amazon they
don't say these are the books selling in
america this is the world and i'm still
number one i've been number one i've
been the the best-selling lgbt book for
a week
and i put my heart and soul into that
book and and with with the objective and
the goal of getting on that list
so that i could represent the lgbt
community as its most prominent
figure and speaker uh
and yet i'm being attacked in this way
it it's
very very upsetting to me
shame on you media matters
and uh glad the gay and lesbian alliance
against defamation they've joined in
okay these media matters
the gay lesbian alliance against
defamation you should be on my side i'm
the one being defamed as the number one
most prominent best-selling lgbt author
in the country in the world
but they're coming out against me and
they put out this way they say this is
horrible
amazon please remove this book from the
lgbtq category immediately
it is absolutely not an lgbtq book it
specifically targets transgender people
with hateful
and dehumanizing rhetoric
where can i turn now
as
the leading voice
as my generation's leading voice in the
lgbt community
where can i turn i can't turn to glad i
can't turn to media matters
i'm a man without a home i'm a man on an
island
um let's read a little bit more from
this
johnny the walrus is an anti-trans
allegory that compares a child imagining
that he's a walrus to society affirming
and accepting trans youth including by
providing life-saving best practice
medical care when kids go through
puberty
in reality now i just want to point out
okay
i the word transgender does not appear
in a book at any point so if you read
the book and
you think there might be similarities
between
what we do with quote unquote trans kids
and a kid pretending to be a walrus i
mean if you are drawing those
connections and connecting those dots
maybe you should think a little bit
more about that
um
and uh
the description of the children's book
claims that it is about a little boy
with a big imagination named johnny who
forced to make a decision between the
little boy he is and the things he
pretends to be
the book depicts johnny first pretending
to be a walrus by using wood spoons as
tusks and socks as fins then going
through the process of trying to become
a walrus by eating worms putting on gray
makeup and visiting a doctor who offers
a simple procedure to cut his feet into
fins
notably amazon has faced backlash for
selling anti-trans books in the past
the company continues to sell the book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters by
anti-trans author abigail schreier even
though employees of amazon filed an
internal complaint in april claiming
that the book violates the company's
policy against selling books that frame
lgbtq identities as a mental illness
um
and uh then it goes on okay so they're
they're very upset
they're very upset that the book exists
they're very very upset that it got on
the lgbt list
which was amazon's call not mine
but i'm honored by it
and uh and this is what they're doing
rampant homophobia over at media matters
disgraceful
all right what else we got
uh
this is from
okay this is just a quick thing i want
to mention real quick the bbc reports uh
that finland's prime minister is uh 36
years old
and went out clubbing until 4 am now you
can see it right there so she left her
work phone at home and uh and uh
and she and she they said finland's
prime minister 36 year old what went out
clubbing until 4 am left her work phone
at home and was therefore unreachable to
get a text telling her that she needed
to quarantine
so santa marine is her name and most
people are on the internet because
they're very immature um they're
commenting on the fact that she's easily
the most attractive world leader you
know on earth and that's true i just
want to say it is a very low bar not
taking anything away from her
because our politicians and this is
something that
is kind of interesting when you think
about it because you would think
especially in the in the age of media
um there would be this requirement and
given how superficial we all are there'd
be a requirement that our politicians be
attractive but there really isn't
apparently our politicians are mostly
extremely ugly and it's embarrassing
we've got a bunch of disfigured dorks
running the world so the standards are
very minimal and she easily exceeds them
but my bigger point here is what sort of
person goes clubbing at 36 years old
you know she didn't quarantine didn't
have her phone she's she's the leader of
the country we'll put it out also but 36
years old
and out clubbing the oldest age for
clubbing is probably 22
which means that if you live in america
you have basically one year where you
can do it legally and uh it's not
completely pathetic
only a little bit
by 23 you're you're too old at 25 you at
a club you look like a like a like an 80
year old at a skate park or something
but to be doing that at 36 is pretty
absurd
um
all right let's move to this we
mentioned yesterday the dante rights uh
situation kim potter the officer that
shot dante wright
is on trial or trial started this week
and they did jury selection yesterday
now fox has
reached out to and has now gotten on
film one of dante wright's victims and
we've i don't think we've ever seen this
before so this is new
where one of the victims of dante right
we went through his list of crimes that
he committed before fighting the cops
and getting himself shot by kim potter
when they were trying to bring him in
because he had a warrant for his arrest
they originally told us remember the
media said uh originally that uh that
they were trying to arrest him
because he had an air freshener in his
car
in fact the original story was
that uh he had an air freshener hanging
from his from his uh rear view
uh mirror and so they pulled him out of
the car and shot him and executed him
and there were all these there were all
these texts they're all these tweets
from people on the left saying
what kind of country is this where a man
can be executed on the spot for having
an air freshener
well turns out that's not the case at
all air freshener had nothing to do with
it uh he did commit some kind of traffic
violation that's why they pulled them
over and then they discovered because
they run your plates and they look at
your id and they say oh look look at
this this is a violent felon and there's
a warrant for his arrest stemming from a
gun charge
um
and that's why they brought him in
then we start finding out information
about his past and the one revelation
that i hadn't known i don't think anyone
knew until yesterday was reported by fox
is that dante wright had previously shot
a 16 year old kid in the head
and that person fortunately managed to
survive but they're now disabled for the
rest of their lives
and dr wright did that but he also
committed armed robbery against a woman
and uh sexually assaulted her in the
process and choked her
and now we have fox tracked this woman
down and she was willing to go on camera
and here she is talking about her
experiences and what it's been like and
uh again we've never seen this from one
of these blm martyrs where one of their
victims is actually willing to speak on
camera so let's watch a little bit of
this
yeah we were hanging out and drinking
and smoking and stuff um
and we
it was just very casual um
neither of them
flirted with me or her and tried to
pursue anything in any other type of way
it was just simply like
we're just hanging out
so i didn't like think of anything you
know they're being really nice
somehow
a conversation got brought up
i talked about my ex and how i've had an
abusive past and so that's why i was
kind of
sketched out about
having images bring this guy over i
didn't know and i messed like in the
snapchat messages
i had said that like i don't know if i
feel comfortable with someone i don't
know coming over
just because this just happened like i
just got out of a
relationship where i'm having trouble
trusting men
um
and it's just
yeah and they
end up don dante himself
like actually
we were we had started talking and he
said that
any man who
who puts his hands on
on a woman and abuses them deserves to
rot in jail and so that was very ironic
to me people have done that to me over
and over and over and over and so
like when he did it it was just lashed
off me it's like how many men are going
to take money for you for you to finally
stand up for yourself
and so like that's kind of how it was
for me i didn't
want him to take it because
i was tired of men
taking advantage of me and walking all
over me
and trying to like
make me feel
worthless
now if if feminists
were not for the most part soulless
cowards they would be celebrating this
woman
um
treating her as a hero because in fact
what she's doing here is is actually
heroic and uh takes a whole lot of
courage
you know there's a reason why
we as i said we never see this
every blm
every blm martyr has
has left a trail of victims in their
wake
and then they're celebrated and
canonized and they've got their murals
all over the place
which means that the the victims of this
person they have to walk by i mean
imagine george floyd's victim
and we've never seen anything from her
we don't even know
i'm not even sure if we know her name
but she has to walk by
and see his mural and and uh and you
know schools are gonna be named after
him and they're gonna have george floyd
laws and every legislation named after
and she has to live in that world now
where the man who abused her is
celebrated as a martyr
so many women have been in this position
and you can see why they wouldn't want
to come and speak out
because there's almost nothing in it for
them
the media is not going to list they're
not going to care feminists are not
going to rally behind them
they just put themselves in line for
more abuse by speaking out so it takes a
whole lot of courage to do it
and she and that's exactly what she's
doing and on top of that what she's
talking about in that clip there
where she says i didn't want to let him
do it it's happened too many times what
she's referring to
is that when dante wright who was in who
she was skeptical about inviting him
into the home just because she didn't
know him
and she decides to do it anyway and she
lets him stay the night there
and he's an absolute sociopath no and
she had shared with him
how she's been abused in the past and
and what that's what that's done to her
and he's listening to that according to
her story
and saying oh yeah any man who does that
is terrible knowing what he plans to do
absolute sociopath like i said yesterday
this guy's he's a monster
this is not a misguided youth this is a
monstrous person
we're supposed to weep
that he's gone and that the world is now
deprived of his presence i don't weep i
don't mourn it
i'd say that i am not sad that that a
guy like dante wright is god i am not
so he's sitting there and he you know
hatches this plan
and then we also know by the way
right before the next morning he decides
he's gonna he's gonna stick the gun in
her face and rob her
and he goes into the to her bathroom
before he does this and he starts taking
pictures for instagram posing with his
gun
and the police have those we know that
that
that those are out there
so it certainly lends a lot of
credibility to her
story um when he points a gun at her
face starts reaching his hand into her
bra sexual assault looking for the money
it's choking her and she doesn't give it
to him she actually fights back
and um
and he ends up running away
without getting the money she had like
eight hundred dollars in cash from her
job on her and uh she ends up she keeps
it she fights back against a guy
pointing a gun at her and says i'm not
giving you this money
and uh he runs away
and now she's out in front of the media
speaking the truth about this guy
this is a very courageous woman and uh
but not gonna get any credit at all from
feminists or from anyone in the media
okay next we have from the daily wire it
says pro-life activists and abortion
advocates are gearing up for an intense
political battle in the states of uh if
roe v wade and a precedent from the
decisions that followed it are
overturned and now a new poll from
politico shows how americans might be
looking at abortion heading into the
midterm elections according to politico
42 percent of respondents to the poll
said they would vote for a candidate who
doesn't align with their views on
abortion compared to 32 percent who said
that the candidate's stance will
determine their vote
another 26 percent were unsure or had no
opinion on the matter the poll also
discovered that 44 percent of people who
were part of the survey said they had
not they had heard not much or nothing
at all about the mississippi case almost
two-thirds either said they didn't know
how likely the court was to overturn roe
or said that the court isn't likely to
overturn the president
the precedent the poll also went into
details regarding how respondents
consider abortion in general total 52 of
respondents said abortion should remain
legal in most or all cases compared to
36 percent who said it should be banned
in most or all cases
and 45 said row should not be overturned
compared to 24 who said it should be
okay
the interesting thing about think about
a poll like this is that it gives you no
matter what side of the issue you're on
there are things that you can latch on
to
and call it a win for your side
um
one thing that i've actually seen some
conservatives
talk about the results of this poll in a
positive way because it seems to
indicate unlike what you hear from the
left now the left says well if roe is
overturned it's going to be a huge voter
backlash against republicans and
conservatives
and uh this poll would seem to indicate
that's probably not going to be the case
but then on the negative side if you're
a pro-lifer it's yeah more than 50
according to the poll anyway we think
that abortion should remain legal the
main thing we take from this poll
and this is this is the greatest hurdle
for pro-lifers and it always has been
and it remains the greatest hurdle even
though the pro-life movement has made
great strides especially in the last 10
years or so
even
no matter what happens with this case
whether roe was overturned or not the
pro-life movement has made enormous
strides over the last 40 years and
especially over the last 10.
but the greatest hurdle that we face in
the pro-life movement has always been
and still is
not the people who disagree with us
but it's apathy
that's the greatest hurdle
that
the majority of people are kind of
apathetic about it they don't have
strong feelings one way or another
you know i would rather hear i would
rather a poll
uh
tell me that a majority of americans are
passionately in favor of abortion i
would rather that
than a poll where you find out that a
majority of americans are kind of like
yeah i don't know i'm not paying
attention
because at least when people are
passionate then they're engaged on the
issue
you could talk to them about it
you know there's there's something there
that you can kind of
grab on to
um
but when people are apathetic the first
thing you have to do is get them to care
and once you've done that then you have
to convince them that you're right about
your position
the convincing them that you're right in
my experience is a lot easier than
getting them to care
that's the hardest part is getting
people to care if they don't
and if it's the kind of person who
doesn't naturally automatically care
about the fact that 60 million babies
have been killed
if they're already apathetic about that
and kind of yawning and shrugging their
shoulders
it is a it is a that is quite an
obstacle to get over it's not impossible
but it's an obstacle and so that remains
i think the greatest challenge for the
pro-life movement all right hillary
clinton was interviewed on the today
show where she read a portion of the
speech that she would have given had she
won the presidency and it is
equal parts pitiful and hilarious let's
watch it
so i didn't as you know write a
concession speech because even though we
had a lot of bumps those last 10 days uh
i i still thought you know we could pull
it out so i worked on um a speech that
really
was about my journey and
had had a real emphasis on my mother's
life and journey as a way of you know
making it clear that yes i would be the
first woman president but
i i like everybody uh stood on the
shoulders and
lived the
lives uh and experiences of those who
came before us a dream of going up to
her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states oh
that's great i hadn't even
watched that entire clip because i
couldn't get through it it was so
cringe-inducing
that is uh
that's even better than her tweet that
she sent out where she uh wished herself
a happy birthday to this future
president
and that tweet lives in infamy
uh and she's roundly mocked for it but
here she goes and does this as well
that's amazing
she cannot get over the fact that she
did not win
it has ruined her
but imagine being such a megalomaniac
such a narcissist
that your
your life is ruined by the fact that
you're not the president
right there's it's there's there's only
been a relative handful of presidents of
american presidents that have existed
you know like the vast majority of
americans who ever lived vast vast magic
like
99.99999 et cetera nine percent of all
americans have have they've done many
amazing things but they haven't been
president
so if you're not the president all that
means is that you're you're just in that
category with almost every other
american who has ever lived
and uh to be utterly devastated by that
fact
just shows what a narcissist she is and
she also says i thought i was curious
she says that
she was standing on the shoulders of
those who came before her okay i'm
familiar with that phrase then she says
i lived the lives of those who came
before me
is this some sort of
hindu reincarnation thing that she's
doing i don't quite understand all right
one other thing really quick this is uh
pretty fascinating we played for you
yesterday a couple days ago the museum
in dc that now offers an audio tour
with a genderless voice
so uh the genderless voice is a new
thing and it's quickly become it's
quickly catching fire and becoming
pretty common and now cnn has actually
jumped on the bandwagon and they had a
news report yesterday uh delivered by a
genderless voice so let's play clip
seven check this out you know the
biggest media story this weekend it's
the firing of chris cuomo from this
network cnn now i've been working the
phones ever since this was announced
yesterday uh evening
frankly i've been on the phone to the
last five minutes here getting
information about what happened
wow so lifelike yet so
neutered
that's all that was the joke and i i
guess i totally stole that joke from
somebody in the youtube comments by the
way so credit to the sbg member who came
up with that one well if you own a home
and have it refinanced what are you
waiting for now is the time to do it
because mortgage rates are historic lows
again which means you could easily drop
your rate and your monthly payment and
we could all yeah we could all use a
little bit extra money every month
especially these days with everything
being so expensive all you've got to do
is call american financing america's
home for home loans take advantage of a
free mortgage review that's right free
meaning there's no pressure no
obligation no upfront fees
just a simple conversation with a
salary-based mortgage consultant
somebody who is going to listen and
guide you so you're getting a custom
loan that achieves your goals from lower
rates to shorter terms even the ability
to access cash from your equity they're
ready to find you the best deal possible
you could save up to a thousand dollars
a month you may be even you may you may
be able to also skip to mortgage
payments so you're getting a lot of
upfront savings as well and you can
pre-qualify for free by calling
866-569-4711
that is
eleven again that's eight 866-569-4711
six five six nine forty seven eleven or
visit americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls one eight two
three three four nmls consumeraccess.org
now let's get to the comment section
they're the sweet baby gang
[Music]
dex says hey matt actual spanish speaker
here the guy who corrected you about
bench is wrong
both el banco and la blanca can both
mean the bench or bar stool or the
financial institution
so you're correct
all right so i was still i was right
well that's good to know but now i'm
even more confused
so if you refer to el banco in spanish
the person you're talking to they won't
know if you mean a bank a bar stool or a
bench
i guess this is why i took three years
of spanish and none of it i mean not one
little bit of it
actually seeped in
which is why by the way teaching foreign
languages in a this is a separate
subject but teaching foreign languages
in a public school setting is a total
waste of time
okay you're not going to teach someone i
know that they do it to kind of check
the box and the the diversity box and
everything
but nobody's going to learn a foreign
language by being exposed to it for 45
minutes at a time like three days a week
for
you know for for a couple of years
if you're gonna learn a language you
have to be immersed in it really and uh
so there's just no point doing it lt
says what did you think about beau bert
congressman bobert taking a christmas
picture with all of her kids holding
guns the libs were hysterical she goes
to the matt walsh school of trolling
apparently
and yeah you can see the picture there
um
and she was so that's the picture all of
her kids were holding guns the bobert's
have your six uh representative thomas
massey representative massey was the
first one to take a picture where he was
with his kids and his wife and they were
all holding guns and they were they were
in front of a christmas tree it was like
a christmas there was a christmas card
picture and uh and then the libs were
pretty mad about that and so then bobert
does her own and the libs were mad about
that one too
i might surprise you i'm i'm a little
bit here
and i'm going to be a total lib about
this
not really not that bad but i will say
that i'm not very crazy about posing
with guns for photos
it's one thing if you're like doing
something with a gun and someone takes a
picture of you like you're out hunting
or target practice or something but just
posing with the gun
for the picture
especially for the purpose of trolling
the libs
now guns are great
trolling the libs is great obviously but
i don't like combining the two
especially when kids are involved
because it sends the message that the
gun is a toy and it's a i mean
what you're saying is that it's a prop
because you're literally using it as a
prop
um
and it's not that right guns are tools
that's what they are
they aren't anything
more or less than that
and i think that's the message that we
should send when the libs are really
angry about guns our message should be
you're freaking out about a tool that's
all it is
it has a certain purpose now some people
like to collect them people like to
collect tools that's fine
but if you saw someone
this is what i look at it i look at it
like this if you saw someone posing for
a staged picture with a hammer
right
because they wanted everyone to think
that they you know that they're
construction worker and that they like
to go out
back to the shed and build decks or
whatever um
if you saw that you would think this
person's kind of a dork
and that's sort of how i feel about
posing for pictures with your guns to
impress people or to show off or
to upset people or whatever
it's a bit dorky and it also gives the
wrong impression about guns i think
especially to kids
i think it's there's nothing wrong at
all with exposing kids to gun guns early
on i think you should
because you're teaching them how to be
around guns you're making it less
mysterious
you know if you have the gun in your
house and you treat it as this
mysterious thing and you say don't even
don't even look at that item right which
is what a lot of parents end up doing if
they have guns but then you're just
making it
you're keeping your kid in ignorance
first of all about the gun and they're
not gonna know how to use it or be safe
around it but you're just making them
more interested in it in the wrong kind
of way
so to get rid of the mystery and say
this is a gun it's a tool
uh if you use it the right way then it's
perfectly safe if you don't really
horrible things could happen
so i think that's a great thing to teach
kids
but when you have them posing for
pictures and everything then again i
think it just kind of sends the message
that this is a toy this is a prop and so
i'm not big into that
um
social hazard says it seems when someone
from the daily wire writes a book that's
all they want to talk about michael
knowles didn't shut up about speechless
and now matt walsh is doing the same
well yeah this is like complaining that
the only thing kellogg's wants to talk
about is kellogg's cereal it's
you know it's not the only thing we talk
about but when you have a book you have
to market it that's it's a product that
you're marketing
so i'll let you behind the curtain a
little bit that's that's what that's all
about
although i i do agree with you
in general that one of the unfortunate
things about releasing a book is that
you have to talk about it all the time
and you do you have to
to let people know that it's out there
and so that you'll sell the copies
uh your publisher kind of requires that
going into it you have to talk about it
but that's why i like johnny the walrus
because there's so much
surrounding this book to talk about and
it's all so funny
that actually it's been a joy to promote
the book
and uh
patrick says matt which food
uh would you be going would be worth
going out at 2 a.m during a
polar vortex for mine is white castle
yeah definitely not subway like
jesse smilet
i mean sub it's it's never worth going
into subway at any time of day no matter
the temperature
you're better off picking
pieces of a sandwich out of the garbage
at like a firehouse sub or a jersey
mike's or something than going into
subway
i'd probably go out at 2 a.m for five
guys
i mean the restaurant
smellette might go out for five guys two
at 2 am as the buying administration
continues to attempt to force vaccine
mandates on american citizens it's more
important than ever that we continue to
fight it and so so far you know the
pushback has been working um it's been
successful not only has the osha mandate
received a nationwide stay this week a
federal court enjoined the binding
administration from enforcing its
federal contractor vaccine mandate as
well so this is where we're having real
success with this fighting back against
the butt administration it's all great
news but it's it's uh doesn't mean that
we should take this and stop applying
pressure and get apathetic we don't want
to do that as the bite administration
itself is not backing down most recently
biden announced his winter covered plan
which which includes the extension of
the federal mass mandate for public
transportation as well as the
consideration of requiring americans to
be fully vaccinated in order to fly
domestically which means that if you
want to visit your family for the
holidays you might have to drive all
across the country instead of taking a
plane that's what they want to do and
that's why we have to continue to fight
back
but we need your help if you haven't
signed our petition against buy-ins
vaccine mandate yet i need you to head
over to dailywire.com do not comply to
add your name we have so far 750 000
signatures we want to get to 1 million
because that's when you really make a
statement so go to dailywire.com do not
comply and if you haven't heard yet i am
the top lgbt author in the world media
matters doesn't like it i love it though
i think it's great uh i think everyone
else can appreciate how wonderful that
is and if you want to be a part of this
lgbt
uh literary sensation if you want to
have a copy for yourself well i don't
have a copy with me somehow i don't have
my johnny the walrus copy i knew i was
missing something from the show um but
you can get your own copy at
johnnythewallrisk.com reserve your your
copy now of this timely
important masterpiece
johnnythewalrus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel prince harry
who we really shouldn't be calling
prince anymore but i'm not sure how else
to refer to him feels sort of weird to
just say harry so for lack of a better
name prince harry was interviewed by the
website fast company where he delivered
insights and advice on a number of
topics despite having no special insight
into any of them or any other topic most
absurdly he had a few tips for
navigating the working world now this is
strange coming from a man who has never
had a job in his life
well up until now i mean that's not true
anymore he has a job now he is a working
man
jumping in the pickup truck every day
lunch pail in hand punching the clock
over at the mental health company better
up where he is a chief impact officer
now i have no idea what a chief impact
officer is i assume it's the corporate
equivalent of being a figurehead in the
royal family so prince harry is perfect
for the job i suppose out of curiosity i
did look up the the title of chief
impact officer on google to see what
role a person in such a position fills
in the company
and i found an explanation on a website
called kindred
apparently says this site
there are two positions that sometimes
get confused there's chief impact
officer and then chief purpose officer
um so we have one chief in charge of
impact and another one in charge of
purpose and here's what it says
chief purpose officers and chief impact
officers have similar objectives to
drive impact through organizations
mission vision and values however there
are key differences between the two
roles that make them distinct
generally cpos operate on a micro scale
internally ensuring that a company's
purpose is embedded throughout its
practices
on the other hand cios tend to have an
external focus around the impact of the
businesses activities and how they align
with the company's mission and values
okay well that clears things up needless
to say chief impact officer prince harry
has a lot a lot of advice to offer folks
in the working world and his first piece
of advice is that you should quit
that's the advice
reading from the interview the question
is covet has accelerated a lot of trends
in the workplace like increased burnout
and job resignations how have you
adapted your strategy to address these
things here's the answer from prince
harry
that's such a great question because it
brings us back to the thesis of better
up and the work alexi and eddie and the
team have been doing for the past eight
plus years before i arrived and also my
personal belief and work in the mental
fitness space while on the surface it
looks like these last couple of years
brought all these issues to the
foreground the reality is that these
struggles and issues have been brewing
for quite some time
we are just at the beginning of the
mental health awakening this work has
never been more important because people
are finally paying attention and a big
component of this mission is building
awareness and continuing to pioneer the
conversation i've actually discovered
recently courtesy of a chat with better
up science board member adam grant that
a lot of the job resignations you
mentioned aren't all bad in fact it's a
sign that with self-awareness comes the
need for change
most people around the world have been
stuck in jobs that didn't bring them joy
and now they're putting their mental
health and happiness first
this is something to be celebrated
now we're going to try our best to
breeze past phrases like mental fitness
space and pioneer the conversation the
thing to focus on here is that prince
harry is telling us to celebrate
quitting
there's been a lot of that kind of thing
in our culture recently as you remember
the most heroic and laudable performance
at the olympics said the media was
simone biles when she quit on our team
because quitting is the new heras
heroism
we used to think that it took courage
and tenacity to do things you don't want
to do
in order to achieve some greater goal
now we say that the real courage in
tenacity is to throw up your hands and
say never mind this is too hard i quit
prince harry says that it's good to quit
your job in order to put your mental
health and happiness first
and you should do this
if your job doesn't bring you joy quote
unquote
now what he forgets to mention is that
he was born rich and will be rich for
the rest of his life through no effort
of his own
he could afford to wait until he was 37
to get his first job which isn't even a
real job but most people are not in that
position
so as always the leftist ethic is is not
only wrong but born from privilege
for most people quitting your job will
leave you unemployed
and poor
which is certainly not the path to
mental health and happiness the
unemployed are not traditionally seen as
a community which best exemplifies
mental health and well-being
now if you can leave your job for a new
one a better one that's great
but then we're talking about changing
jobs not simply quitting jobs
what you cannot do in spite of prince
harry's suggestions
or should not do
is leave your job because it doesn't
make you happy and then wait around on
the unemployment line until a happier
job comes along
this is an especially bad idea because
it's very unlikely that you'll ever find
any job that makes you happy and brings
you joy
and that's not to say that that your job
ought to make you miserable or that you
ought to stick with a job that you hate
indefinitely by all means look for
another job while you currently still
have the one you hate and then make the
switch once the new job is secured but
for a lot of miserable people in the
workforce the problem is that they're
expecting something from a job that a
job can't provide them joy is found in
that which most deeply fulfills you
completes you as jerry maguire would say
joy is found in your faith your family
your passions
now a very small group of people on
earth might make a living doing the
thing that they are absolutely the most
passionate about
most people do jobs that pay the bills
and a job that you know they could feel
like they could they contribute
something worthwhile
and where there's career advancement
and financial stability and so on
prince harry looks down on that
from a position of privilege he says no
if you aren't deeply on fire with
passion about your job
just quit
as a multi-millionaire born with a
silver spoon and a literal royal crown
on his head that's a strategy that he's
able to pursue but most people can't
and in fact there's something quite
admirable i think
and dignified and good about people who
work jobs that they maybe don't love
and yet they do it in order to fulfill
their responsibilities and to care for
their families and so on
for them the job is an act of love for
those who depend on them
and they do find joy there not so much
in the job itself perhaps but in the
reason for the job
you know i think about the guys who
collect the the garbage in my
neighborhood especially in the summer in
the south when it's 95 degrees with
humidity of 145 percent and all the
trash is putrid and covered in maggots
and they have to come to my house where
we've got dirty diapers in the trash
that have been stewing there for six
days
um
does that bring them joy
is the job itself a cause of joy or
happiness
would prince harry approve
now i don't know for sure i'm not inside
their heads of course but but but i'm
gonna guess it's not
i'm gonna guess the the act of cleaning
up garbage does not in itself bring joy
does that mean that those guys aren't
happy or joyful no certainly not in fact
from the outside anyway they appear to
be very cheerful more cheerful than me
in the morning when i'm on my way to a
job in a climate-controlled environment
where i sit here in my comfortable chair
which a sponsor pays me to sit in
they're more cheerful probably because
they know something about happiness that
prince harry does not know and i
struggle to keep in mind half the time
and that is that happiness is so often a
matter of what you choose to pay
attention to where you choose to set
your focus
you can be miserable in the greatest job
in the world or doing the most fun thing
or even around your loving and beautiful
family if you choose to pay attention to
the aspects of those experiences that
you don't like
happy people are mentally disciplined
they know how to control their emotional
attention
and here's the other secret of happiness
that you'd hope the chief of happiness
at a mental health company would know
but he doesn't
the worst thing you can do if you want
to be happy is actively try to be happy
if you're pursuing happiness for its own
sake you're not going to find it
if you're looking simply for a job that
makes you happy
you will never find it
you have to shoot for things beyond that
things perhaps more solid more firm and
then you'll find happiness in the
bargain
so all parents know that family
vacations for example especially with
young children are very stressful and
there tends to be a lot of unhappiness
involved in them ironically
and the reason is that it's a big
elaborate thing that you're doing with
the express purpose of being happy so
you're saying okay from this day to this
day we're going to spend x amount of
money from our vacation budget to be
happy
and then things don't go exactly as you
plan and you aren't as happy as you
wanted and then you become even less
happy because you're mad that you aren't
happy
this is a microcosm of life the happiest
moments you have as a family are the
times when you're
not all trying desperately to be happy
you're just being together for the sake
of being together and then you find oh
look at that we're happy
i think the same holds true on an
individual basis it's true at your job
you can even find happiness while
cleaning up trash maybe not because of
the trap trash but alongside it
happiness can be found in many
unexpected places you just have to stop
expecting it
and as for your job try to find
something that will allow you to care
for yourself and your family where you
can utilize your skills
where you can have some financial
stability
hopefully contribute something to the
world
and if you find that
and you focus on the right things
you'll probably find happiness
as long as you aren't looking too hard
for it
and those are all the reasons why
who's canceled oh yeah prince harry is
canceled today and that'll do it for us
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show california
unveils a plan to become an abortion
sanctuary if roe versus wade is
overturned i am so glad i took my
company and left that's today on the
bench bureau should i give it a
listen you